what's going on guys we have a brand new
Captain America civil war trailer to
talk about just dropped have you were
you waiting all morning for this crap
like all of us it's like come on
tick tock one's that thing gonna drop
well we've watched it it's out there and
we're gonna talk about and we have a
pretty awesome panel of comic book heads
to talk about it with let me introduce
these folks first he is from superhero
news the handsome and talented
hey I'm talking a monkey I'll say
whatever you want me to say it's too
late got to get it in before so uh and
oh he's been with us before welcome back
writer actor host of Marvel movie news
and the biggest Deadpool fan that I know
in the world poisoned row I know man
great to see you buddy good - thanks for
being here and also host of Marvel movie
news co-hosts
and the producer of fat man on Batman
Mackie
hey everybody glad to be back what is
going on fellas so first impressions
right out the gate mat let's start with
you down on the end um I'm not gonna
like I'm not gonna my first impression
I'm not gonna say anything about
spider-man cuz III know that these two
guys like live and breathe
Thanks Doctor Strange that mat yeah
exactly exactly you're not gonna like
drop on Doctor Strange and you know so
it looks at the stakes are real like
that's the thing about this movie that
I'm the most excited about is that the
stakes are very real and you see that
like from the offset where they're like
here's all these disasters that you guys
have been around and had a hand in
Avengers Washington New York Washington
sokovia you know and then you know you
you so you see down you're like oh man
yeah like this is a world isn't like
chaos like oh my god and then you see
Scarlet Witch and she's like kind of
like tearing up and Captain America's
like alright that's enough and you just
like you see like the emotional stakes
from the yeah
Dowling an area this one was more of a
story trailer than like an action
trailer like the last few ones I think
are more exciting because there's more
in action you stuff happening but in
this one it slowly builds today I'm
talking about the score from the offset
you can you tell what this movie is
because that meant haunting those keys
they strike down the very beginning that
this movie has a very specific flavor we
haven't really seen before it reminded
me of the concept that Dark Knight
touched upon ya are saying like you know
escalation where you have you know
you're you're a guy dressed in a bat
suit and then he pulls out the Joker
card this only to me you felt like
escalation on a global scale we have
look at what you guys cause because
you're so big and powerful look at the
power that like is wrought on the earth
yeah and Iron Man's take on that with
him having to have some sort of checks
and balances love it as he doesn't come
of it yeah as to me more rounded real
than it did in the comics yeah I know
Iron Man in the comics yeah cuz of
Downey jr. I actually reread Civil War
yeah Andrea appreciated both sides
because before I was like Iron Man a
douchenozzle yeah but with Downey jr.
I'm like oh I see it but this feels
balanced and real and like something
that could happen and that's amazing
yeah Iron Man fighting Captain America
I'm like Absalom like that yeah and um I
think Hector made a great point where as
this really lays out what is happening
um in this world so for the uninitiated
to Marvel Civil War the comics you see
oh okay so this series events
precipitated this I thought they did
that nicely
the general public yeah and I don't
think they really hit it that hard but
for the comic book fans and for people
that know the general story there's an
inciting incident the beginning of this
thing and it's that explosion it's
probably gonna be like a United Nations
thing because yeah T'Challa is there
tall is there a Chaka is there from what
Conda and that's how Black Panther gets
reference in the comic books Black
Panther stayed out of it for the most
part you know because it was in
Connecticut United States thing knees
what kind of but yeah that's a great way
to loop him into it absolutely in that
moment with chadwick boseman like crying
in the passion I'm like oh that's gonna
be incredible it's gonna be great yeah
so um do you like that adaptation
because yeah in the comics it's
precipitated by different incidents it's
more like that superhero reality show
the new
the new warriors that what was this damn
Stanford Stanford yeah but I feel like
they things add up nicely and it makes
sense
yeah actually think this is more rounded
more real and I think it ties it MCU is
a really special place once you accept
that the comics and the films are
completely separate animals you'll have
a better time okay I think this is going
to be a better well-rounded story I love
Civil War but this is shaping up I think
to be a better overall
yeah adaptation of the concept that's
all were touched on okay I can't wait
any longer I got to talk about it see it
kind of as you see us more so we're
waiting for it yeah and for a second I'm
like oh they're not gonna give it to us
and then the web pulls the shield oh man
and the second they show the Civil War
tag at the end us like oh my god Spider
Man said like there's still like 30
seconds left there's gonna be spider-man
it's gonna be spider-man it is midnight
last night you start refreshing slash
okay oh my God look at that oh you know
an incredible introduce yes oh my god
you guys are just losing it go back to
the first shot before his eyes closed
yeah very John Muir scene your eyes and
when you have a second shot yeah you're
freaking Steve Ditko eyes yeah that
we've literally got the two most iconic
images of a Spider Man head and with
five seconds well we have two frames
compare different errors of spider-man
damn but like they've also got like the
black likes right it looks like so
that's a mission that we haven't seen in
the comics correct like the black piping
or whatever there's Cameron suit a
little a little bit the albatross yes
it's got like it's the colors are
perfect I know you get the boots down
there a little bit yeah on the boots and
the next year and and one thing we
haven't seen before in a screen
adaptation of spider-man is the belt
yeah so talk to me about the
significance of the belt people already
put it out he's got mechanical
web-shooters and he's got extra
cartridges cartridges
webbing what job does in the comic books
but it's like hidden under his cloth
costume and he still looks like a nude
man you know there's not that sort of
detailing until the Scarlet Spider came
around in the 90s but you're like a
bulky web shooter on the end yeah anyway
the point is is that I'm a spider-man
costume purist oh yeah this is the best
costume in comic book history I think it
is perfect and I love it to be that
original sort of like Romita era like
when he sort of refined the Ditko stuff
but having seen that I'm like oh my god
they did it its iconic on guys it feels
like it fits into dick oh is it feels
like it still fits into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that this is
something that Robert Downey jr. Tony
Stark could have designed for Peter
Avengers costume but it's still this is
also the first time that we've seen
expressive eyes from Spy Who I am what
do you think of that edition I think
that a very Deadpool right I mean that
was a spider-man and Deadpool was
inspired by spider-man to do it so yeah
that were in a world where now the
Deadpool is doing well they're like well
obviously I think this was playing
before and I think the the $700,000,000
Deadpool's Mays gonna help it do well
but I love that spider-man not only
looks like spider-man but he looks like
what we're we're imagining a modernized
version of spider-man could be yeah I
never thought I'd see a costume that
wasn't my spider-man and you know oh
that's for sure for sure that now I
think Tom Holland is probably the
youngest actor to play spider-man yeah
he did sound a little pubescent excited
because not tell me the cheeki eyes are
matching with this incredible
introduction for this character who
we've seen twice in movies before yes
different actors we've seen him in comic
books in may like for 50 years
oh yeah when he grabs that first of all
he's called underoos by Iron Man item
sickeness underoos which is like all
this because the brilliant thing about
spider-man in the larger world of the
Marvel Universe is that he is a 16 year
old kid and he calls himself spider-man
not spider boy right and he looks up to
people like Captain America the fact
that other superheroes existed inspired
him to put on a costume and listen to
his what his Uncle Ben said which is a
great
responsibilities so the fact that
they're playing with that with that
dynamic those relationships and that
cheeky interrupts it just yeah just so
British mr. Cruz is almost like a kind
of a fourth-wall Deadpool nod we're
under bizarre like a superhero thing
yeah like we hear the webbing and we're
like oh crap it's happening he seals
this shield yeah lands on the car and
then like in the most like reserve just
like you know just the most just oh it's
so perfect
hey everyone yeah what a little joke I
love there's like this element of like
ego where he's like hey guys know I'm
spider-man and I belong in this circle
he's not a 30 year old man like Andrew
Garfield fighting around all day and you
guys probably will after rest of it but
I want to hit a couple other points um
we got a glimpse of I think it was
prison 42 yeah which is it sets up the
negative in the negative zone talk to me
about prison 42 and the significance of
that from the Commonwealth is it are we
sure that it's 40 tour is at the raft
like well this sort of like secret
prison if this thing is probably gonna
take the place of what prison 42 was in
the 600 yeah which was it was where all
the supervillains went like not only
super villains but people who were like
against the Registration Act like even
like heroes like Captain America would
have eventually ended up there this is
something that was supposed to be a
temporary measure this is something that
Tony Stark Hank Pym and Reed Richards
all designed but in the secret and put
into the negative zone which was a nice
night the night that the inciting
incident in Stanford Connecticut and all
these kids in elementary school died
because superheroes would set off the
Civil War that night these three
characters these super scientific
geniuses came up with a hundred ideas to
change the world and number 42 of those
ideas was this prison in the negatives
because they're saying when you get a
super villain in a jail they're just
gonna get it's a revolving door that
just look it out and it's in the
negative zone which is a very hard to
reach place in the Marvel Universe so
and then eventually yeah the plan was we
got to put the superheroes in there
because we're not equipped yet with
regular prisons we want to try to
convert them to our side it was all
supposed to be a temporary measure
so it's a very foreboding image for
the movie because if you know the comic
you know that like that could be for cap
less sure you know that that could play
anyone any hero we love anyone that
shows us to be on cap star that guy yeah
so my my only issue with it is that it
doesn't feel like there's enough like
necessity for air injures sure because
like in marble looks like we've got a
thousand villains and they should all go
into this place and the cinematic
universe we have like this looks like
it's a like seven hundred billion dollar
like in the middle of like the Caspian
Sea you know but listen you can argue
with what agents of shield has been
doing in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with things like Jessica Jones and the
defenders shows that they're all just
hinting at no no there's more characters
we haven't even met yet yeah world is
having bigger everyday solutely I
possibility exists and they could stand
to add some better villains a couple
other things I want to hit Krotz we saw
cross bone in their guerrilla fighting
Captain America especially the Captain
America's fate yeah I think that's
definitely gonna play into it and I
think it was great the Red Skull Doug
brainwash them because he things like
math but we know right we don't we
thought about Don Cheadle's character
anything you know what that's that's a
big okay so I don't think I don't think
that he's dead I don't think they're
gonna show a character having died in
the trailer like that's an Iron Man 3
and young versions of the script and I
think they even shot Jon Favreau's
character dying but then in the end the
final draft the final version of movie
was like no he gets better he's just
watching Downton Abbey like he's sure so
that might happen here when going but
like the the they just released like
that big like 115 things that you should
know I can't remember what website did
it but like they were on the set when
they were shooting that giant airport
scene gotcha and they interviewed all
the actors and everything and one of the
big things that came out of that series
of interviews was that there is like yes
there's the inciting incident to the
very beginning of the film that where
it's just like you guys have got to be
pulled in to check like this is like
yeah yes is he getting out of hand but
then I also and I think it's probably
crossbones it probably frames them would
you yeah and by the way something we
haven't seen yet is Baron Zemo like we
still don't know yeah that's nice that's
a nice thing to wait for for them but
but going back to uh so there's an
incident in the film that is similar to
what happened in the Civil War comic
where like Goliath is climbing alone
Thor gotcha
I think maybe was a war machine thing
could be it I don't think he's dead
interesting but I think that this is
like a holy cow we went how far you did
what you got him out of the sky like and
they see a torsos like oh it came on
like the stakes are very real with any
thoughts about vision and Scarlet Witch
they're gonna fall in love and have a
baby yeah I know I love that shot
because there's also going to be a scene
where a black widow fights Hawkeye I
just love the the pairings of cat
classic characters and then this movie
has to divide them yeah and this is a
classic example that because Scarlet
Witch and vision our vision saves
Scarlet Witch she saved Wanda Avengers
age of Ultron from dying and so I think
they already planting a sense of like
they are gonna have a romantic
relationship which is great that's a
great point that's a great reminder like
it's really exciting to see like Scarlet
Witch how strong she is vision is down
it's like bowling yeah oh man you guys
so I feel like there's an overall
positive reaction I just want to hear
any final thoughts you might have well
let's start and work our way around
seriously all I wanted like everyone is
excited to see spider-man I was excited
to see spider-man what I want to see
more from this trailer than anything and
I mean this with absolute sincerity yeah
was one of two things
yes giant man for ant-man on an arrow
and I saw ant-man on arrow and I
squealed reamed out loud like the
spider-man suite that's my man
that's cool but when I saw a man on an
arrow I was like oh
yeah he like lands between the gullet
and like you just know he's gonna scream
like totally badass man talk to me
thoughts I thought that Spiderman was
revealed in a nice way I didn't feel
like it exposed anything I don't feel
let down I don't feel like I was ruined
I'm worried about that but the most
important thing for me with civil war is
the fact that this sets the bar for the
next level of superhero films and every
movie needs escalation and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is serialized to the
fact in this trailer we see a new tone
to the universe within two and a half
minutes and that changes the entire
outlook of marble thank you
that was beautiful absolutely Hector
that's what we call a nerdgasm yeah okay
one final question
yeah should they have saved the reveal I
would've been fine either way honestly I
would have been fine if they had saved
Spidey but here's what they are saving
for the movie a giant man johnny is
gonna be a badass moment that I think
people that don't read comic books or
know anything about Marvel uh-huh are
gonna be like well Paul wrote just went
big cool yeah and there's Raven Baron
Zemo and out there not some other
nuggets say there they gotta sell
tickets spider-man's
sell tickets yeah yeah I'm really
excited how they're revealed I liked
seeing spider-man and the fact like I
think that was smart to reveal them yes
because there's been salt like we're all
so excited about it now that we've seen
it we haven't wait to see more because
we know much more excited to see more
how do you feel about the reveal we want
to know what you think in the comments
section below let us know I want to
thank this awesome panel of dudes Hector
thank you for being here Hector lavarro
superhero news train boys and ro marvel
movie news and matte team are movie news
fat man on Batman and I want to thank
you for watching also we have a bonus
video go to screen junkies calm and you
can see our brand-new exciting on point
house of cards
idiots guide it is guide to house of
cards it will catch you up we put a lot
of work into that thing and it is a
valuable resource for humanity um again
thanks again thank you for watching I'm
how rudnick hit us all up on Twitter
bye-bye
what I'm saying is I don't know if the
fans will want
damn glow give me your raw prediction
right now how many how many new
Ghostbusters films will there be I think
we're gonna be talking about a GCU in
about four or five years especially if
this film does really well and I think
people forget I even they'll see you
hashtag coin it